extrem seltsame objekte kreisen rasend
schnell um das zentrale schwarze loch in
unserer galaxie sagittarius sterben sie
sehen aus wie staubwolken aber verhalten
sich ganz anders jetzt hat eine
forschungsgruppe die objekte untersucht
und vielleicht ihr geheimnis gelüftet
klicks um science-fiction gibt es
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nicht herzlich willkommen um endlich das
geheimnis der seltsamen objekte zu
lüften analysierte die forschungsgruppe
die daten der vergangenen zwölf jahre
des oasis pressing internet imagine
spectrographs kurz osiris aus dabei
fanden die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler objekte die wie
staubwolken anmuteten aber ihr verhalten
im gravitationsfeld des schwarzen loches
sagittarius a stern er an große objekte
wie sterne erinnert schon vorher wurden
zwei dieser seltsamen objekte entdeckt
aber niemand konnte sich einen reim
drauf waren die objekte g1 und g2 die
eins wurde 2004 entdeckt und g2 2012 mit
der neuen studie kamen aber drei neue
seltsame objekte hinzu g34 und g5 und
sie alle haben diese seltsamen
eigenschaften sie kreisen extrem nah und
extrem schnell um das schwarze loch
lange dachten forscher und forscherinnen
dass es sich um gaswolken handeln würde
aber die einst und g2 hätten schon lange
durch die gravitation des schwarzen
loches auseinandergerissen werden müssen
das ist aber nicht geschehen sie
existieren weiter was für gaswolken in
der nähe eines supermassereichen
schwarzen loches in dieser nähe
eigentlich nicht möglich ist mark morris
forscher am uke galactic center ob
drittes initiativ wenn es sich um
gaswolken handeln würde hätten g1 und g2
nicht intakt bleiben können unsere
annahme ist dass es sich bei dem objekt
um aufgeblähte sterne handels sterne die
so gross geworden sind dass die
gezeitenkräfte die vom schwarzen loch
ausgehen zwar materie abziehen können
wenn die sterne nah genug dran sind doch
die einen stellaren kern mit genügend
masse haben um im takt zu bleiben und
die neuen objekte g34 und g5 verhalten
sich genauso sie sind genau so
aufgebläht wie g1 und g2 und strahlen
hohe mengen an energie aus das
forschungsteam geht jetzt davon aus dass
es sich bei den objekten um kollidierte
sterne handelt sich um
reisen sich und kollidieren schließlich
jetzt warten die forscherinnen und
forscher darauf dass das objekt g3 dem
schwarzen loch so nahe kommt dass es
wenn es eine gaswolke wäre
auseinandergerissen werden würde in 20
jahren wird es soweit sein
und dann soll geht drei dabei beobachtet
werden wie es sich verhält dann erhofft
sich dass sieben so mehr erkenntnisse
über diese objekte zu gewinnen wenn sie
direkt das verhalten am schwarzen noch
beobachten können was passiert in einem
schwarzen loch super video von doktor
watson draufklicken anschauen und doktor
watson abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran